[Music]
good
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the future
game show powered by wd black
i'm laura bailey but you may know me as
abby anderson from the last of us part
two or
kate diaz from gears of war today though
i'll be taking a break from fighting the
apocalypse to bring you a whole host of
exciting game trailers reveals and
updates
but before we get into all that i need
to get my co-host on the line
i'm sure you're gonna be familiar with
this person he's appeared in
the last of us uncharted god of war
you name it he's probably in the credits
so without further ado here is my good
friend
and continual co-star troy baker
hello laura you look amazing as always
uh yes you may know me from a few video
games uh joel miller and the last of us
or good old agent jonesy from fortnite
but over the next
hour or so laura and i are going to be
giving you the
inside scoop of some incredibly exciting
games and also
showcasing developer interviews
exclusive trailers and a whole lot more
including world premieres
there's also a chance to win a 500 gift
card
and a wd black hard drive by following
the link
here and we have a new addition to the
show this year
the virtual show floor more on that
later
but let's kick things off with the first
world premiere
and for that we're going prehistoric
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i wonder if you can put hats on the
dinosaurs
instinction is expected in 2022 what's
next laura
next up grow song of the evertree is a
sandbox adventure about the healing
power of nature
let's throw it over to pridefulsloth hq
to find out more
g'day for profilesoft hq i'm adam and
i'm cheryl and we're the design team on
gross song of the evertree
grow is priceless latest project that
we're working on with 505 games grow
song of the evertree is a beautiful
sandbox game about growing new worlds
building a town and bringing harmony
back to the land grow will be available
later this year on pc playstation xbox
and switch
thanks for watching
once upon a time
[Music]
our lands teamed with creatures great
and small
the beauty of the worlds was unrivaled
the people thrived and lived in harmony
with the land around them
[Music]
but this harmony was not to last
slowly without much notice
the withering was creeping out from the
darkness
once it took hold there was little that
could be done
our lands were overrun and all that was
cherished
disappeared before us but all was not
lost
one young brave soul stayed behind
support from their friends and with
boundless determination
this young soul seeks out a way to push
back the withering
and bring life back to our world
[Music]
grow song of the evertree
that was grow song of the evertree which
is coming to pc
playstation xbox and nintendo switch in
2021 okay laura that was
extremely cute but have you considered
more dinosaurs hmm you can't just hijack
every game reveal and make it about
dinosaurs troy
uh uh uh uh life uh
finds a way
[Music]
this is a very different world
hi i'm rich newbold game director at
frontier developments
so as you may have seen earlier at the
pc game show we're working on jurassic
world evolution 2
we're really excited about it and we're
looking forward to creating the most
authentic jurassic experience yet
we've got tons of new features across
four different game modes
including our original jurassic campaign
which is a story set
after the events of jurassic world
falling kingdom you're going to be
leading efforts to contain control and
conserve all those dinosaurs now running
out in the wild
you'll be working alongside characters
from the films voiced by original talent
such as jeff goldblum and in the game we
have over 75 prehistoric species we've
got new dinosaurs we have returning
community favorites and we've added
flying and marine reptiles to the game
i'm really thrilled to be showing you a
first look at footage from the game
itself
this is a from our species field guide
series of videos focusing on one of the
many prehistoric species we have in the
game
this is an iconic popular dinosaur it's
triceratops but we're showing you it in
a new environment never seen before in
jurassic world evolution
i hope you enjoy it and are looking
forward to the game releasing later this
year
[Music]
the triceratops is one of the most
recognizable herbivores to ever have
existed
it is best known for its trio of facial
horns
these adornments are not just for
display purposes
the brow horns in particular can inflict
considerable damage to
any dinosaur that dares to provoke it
that was jurassic world evolution 2
which is launching in 2021
on pc ps4 ps5 xbox one and
xbox series x and s
okay for this next section we're
bringing the joys of e3
to your home with a series of demos you
can play
right now that's right today this is the
future game show
virtual show floor and remember if any
of the featured games grab your interest
you can try them out now by heading to
the future game show steam page
so let's head down to the show floor
where i believe laura is waiting
yes hello and welcome to the future game
shows virtual e3 show floor
just look at it troy i am looking at it
it is incredible they like nailed it you
know
minus the queuing and the heat and the
you know how do i say
musk that's in the air but man the
darkness perfection
all right enough reminiscing let's check
out some games
i'd like to start by showing you a tale
of paper
this is a striking platformer from open
house games where you transform to solve
puzzles in an oversized world dodging
creepy crawlies and mischievous roombas
and now for another tale of paper as you
shift packing boxes in the house moving
sim get packed fully loaded as you can
see it's all about moving couches
on a couch with your friends in couch
co-op it's going to be available on xbox
one
playstation 4 and pc and is also
backwards compatible
on ps5 and xbox series xns are you
are you done saying couches yes hey
laura do you want a drink
sure what do you have wait what's that
oh oh don't you know don't worry don't
worry about them they're steve early
access codes go go go go go
so about that drink right yeah
sure oh yeah uh here's a genre cocktail
full of co-op action rpg combat and
finished
with a survival twist how does that
sound huh
okay i said how's i heard what you said
tell me about the game this is
gatewalkers
which sees you and up to three other
players banding together to tackle
procedurally generated worlds
full of monsters but you also have to
gather resources to fight off hunger
thirst
and the dreaded cold hot oh like the
element cold
got it wow let's hope no one gets
thirsty enough for another one of your
jokes anyway come over here and check
out the many imaginative worlds
of game deck this is an isometric rpg
that has you solving crimes across
multiple virtual realities where your
choices will shape the world around you
in and outside of the simulations
speaking of detectives check this out
backbone is a gorgeous adventure game
from eggnuts set
in a dystopian vancouver where you must
crack cases to clean house in this
corrupt post noir city
plus you're a raccoon well if you like
raccoons
allow me to offer you more critter-based
adventures with
beacon pines set inside of a magical
storybook
beacon pines sends players to a sleepy
mountain town where you collect
powerful words that can completely alter
the narrative
in this charming but mysterious tale you
know
i'm detecting a theme with the
anthropomorphic animals you know laura
i've always
huh another set of codes
interesting joy focus
i've got a triple threat of fighting
boxes to show you
this is trifox a charming cartoon
brawler where you fight waves of enemies
as one of three
adaptable combat classes great huh
yes totally but now it's time to get
serious
mankind is gone but the beavers remain
welcome to timberborne
it's a unique city builder where players
set out to create the ultimate
beaver society this involves everything
from constructing dams to
crafting carousels i guess even
bucktooth critters need a solid
work-life balance
that they do that they do so what's next
never fear the rift breaker is here
wow what was that
is what i would say if i was playing our
next game which
is a base building survival game where
you hack and slash your way through
hordes of alien creatures look at it
oh no no no no i want to hear more from
the rift breaker
okay maybe after this showcase we're
meant to be hosting
and with that we've reached the end of
our little tour but remember
you can go hands-on with all of these
games right now
by visiting the future game show page on
steam
now how do we quit this is it uh no
oh that's not that's update preference i
don't need to update this
laura can you help me out just suggest a
little bit i got you
okay we're back quick note from here on
in when you see
this pop up on screen during a trailer
it means you can visit the future game
show page on steam
to play a demo and go hands-on with the
game immediately
[Music]
i was doing rocky sorry as far as wanted
to do that it's because our next game is
all about floating like a butterfly
stinging like a bee check out this
exclusive presentation from steel city
interactive
about esports boxing club
coming later in 2021 esports boxing club
brings you the greatest fight roster
in video game history with over 200
fighters already signed
we've got some of the biggest and most
anticipated names greatest
of all time from the absolute legends of
the sport
to the most exciting names in boxing
[Applause]
today the first women's division
ever represented in a video game and the
hottest new talent
[Applause]
but what about the game let's take a
closer look at the next gen visuals and
gameplay that are set to make espc
the greatest of all time it's good
there's definitely one for the grandkids
and stuff to say
well you know granddad was in a game and
busting people up so i
say it's going to be quite cool
so the movement system in espc is all
about fluidity
being able to create angles recreating
mannerisms from boxes
the physics system doesn't just rely on
animation
this allows us to recreate realistic
knockdowns
even when a fighter is unsteady on their
feet it's not purely animation based
now we've had professional boxes
professional coaches
come into the studio and provide input
through motion capture
and actually reviewing the game during
his development
and now we really feel like we've
created a true representation of the
sport
presentation is important to us just
because we are in the studio
we're still going to aim high when it
comes to production values
esports boxing club coming to pc and all
major consoles
with early access in 2021
esports boxing club is coming to pc
playstation 4 playstation 5
xbox one xbox series x and series s
next up we've got a deeply immersive
world war two shooter with over 100
players taking part in epic battles
recreated using aerial photography
and satellite imagery let's take a
closer look at hell let loose
product not yet rated
my name's max rhea i'm the founder of
black matter
and the lead developer of hell led loose
hell let loose began as the idea of a
couple of hobbyist game developers
all the way back in 2015 following a
successful kickstarter we launched into
early access
in the middle of 2019 and since then
we've delivered nine enormous updates
including
entire systems overhauls six new maps
tons of new weapons gadgets and vehicles
as well as expanding our unique
real-time strategy inspired meta game
as a result we've been fortunate to sell
more than a million copies during our
first year of early access
2021 is only going to be bigger
i'm excited to announce that we're
launching out of early access on july
the 27th
with the introduction of the soviet
forces on the eastern front
including famous battles like kursk and
stalingrad
before we close out the year by bringing
hell let loose to next generation
consoles
hell let loose has only grown due to the
vibrant community that surrounds it
from our earliest kickstarter backers to
our newest recruits
we're excited to introduce you to this
ever evolving and expanding world war ii
experience
we hope you enjoy this first look at
what's to come
[Music]
hell let loose is launching on steam on
july 27th and coming to xbox series x
and s and playstation 5 in 2021
so laura have you ever wanted to play
xcom but in real time with up to seven
of your friends
of course yep that's what i thought then
you need to keep your eye on this next
game
hello my name is ceo of ireland
a game dev studio based in croatia and
for the past few years we have been
working on the red solstice 2 game
it is a real time tactical battlefield
game it supports up to 80 players
and has a fully playable coke campaign
we are ready to show you the launch
dealer now
so get ready for june 17th when the game
launches on steam
and have fun blasting some buildings
you are the executive a high high-class
commanding officer with advanced
cybernetic capabilities you were
awakened to lead a secret task force
that will counter the threat of strong
mutants
and liberate mars
[Music]
welcome back executor the stroll
infestation has now infected all
colonies on mars
build your squad from six unique classes
of elite soldier
utilizing their skills to best suit each
mission type
customize their weapons and tech as well
as their upgrades and abilities
[Music]
take command on the battlefield using
the command radio
to give orders to the whole squad or
individual soldiers
concentrate fire on targeted locations
and carry out supply runs
even during the heat of battle recruit
your friends to the fight and join in up
to eight player co-op missions
to save mars in our name
[Music]
purge earth of a mutant invasion in red
solstice 2's survivors which is coming
to steam on june 17th
our next game is about delivering mail
in a sleepy american lakeside town
let's join dylan from gamius to learn
[Music]
more
hi i'm dylan from gamius and it's great
to be here at the future game show
we're currently getting very close to
finishing a lake
a game that's set in the 80s you play as
meredith weiss
who takes a break from her life in the
big city to deliver mail in her hometown
it's a job you can do at your own
leisure and you will get to know the
people in providence oaks along the way
today we're excited to share an example
of an activity
after your work day is done movie night
with angie from the video store
this is fun it's been ages since i've
been to the movies
well they call it the movies plural but
of course we can only see one movie at a
time
so which one will it be
my pick alright let's see
big trouble in little china blue velvet
or the great mouse detective
all right i'm ready to pick
the great mouse detective wouldn't have
picked you for a disney fan
oh well let's get in touch with our
inner child
we won't spoil more and we also can't
say what meredith will do after spending
two weeks in providence oaks
because it's all up to you lake is
coming first to xbox npc
this september 1st thanks for watching
and enjoy the rest of the show
[Music]
we're excited to announce that lake is
coming to steam epic game store and xbox
series x
and s on september 1st now what kind of
a showcase would this be without a new
souls like our next game is a pixelated
take on the genre following a
protagonist with a giant
obsidian sword
in the beginning there was dust
and from that dust the moon was born
eons of idleness passed before suddenly
it shattered great celestial chunks
cascaded from the heavens unto earth
from one prodigious shard spawned
humanity and from another the gods
for a great many years balance endured
until a foul and malevolent deity
intervened
exhale spread greed and distrust among
his kin
compelling these calamitous beings to
conquer
man centuries of servitude passed
until finally aided by a veiled ally
humanity revolted the great crusade
overthrew
the old gods imprisoning them within the
sacred walls
of the citadel at the expense of untold
lies
the peace was warped but it was not
meant to last
for the miscreant exile returned
from his concealment conducting
atrocious experiments upon his caged
kindred
a darkness permeated the lands
rivers stagnated crops failed
and the world man began to fade
the great moon witnessing all
wept
[Music]
obsidian and thus
a glimmer of hope remains
customize your combat style and boss
rush ancient gods when eldest souls
drops onto pc and all current console
formats
july 29 2021 and now we've got a closer
look at the next game from the folks
behind
war thunder here's tom from darkflow
software to guide you through
enlisted
[Music]
hi there thanks for tuning in hopefully
our little trailer has got you
interested
my name's tom and i'm part of the team
of dark flow software behind our new
game
enlisted a historical world war ii
shooter with some unique gameplay quirks
one of enlisted's most unique features
is the squads mode
where you head into battle with a squad
of ai soldiers under your control
you can instruct them on how to react to
enemies and most importantly
you can switch between any of them
seamlessly with the press for button
you'll only need to respawn when your
entire squad is wiped out
this way you're always kept right in the
middle of the action
although if you prefer a more
traditional shooter experience we have a
fleshed out solo mode too
where you will only fight against other
players at its core
enlisted aims to form a golden middle
ground between the more hardcore
and arcade style shooters currently
available time to kill is kept short
a bolt action rifle to the chest will
down a soldier in a single shot
with submachine guns and pistols taking
only a few hits
vehicles as well can of course be
devastating but have their limitations
aircraft restricted to the cockpit view
and crew inside tanks can only use
viewports to spot targets
so you'll need to keep your wits about
you to really get the most out of these
machines
progression and enlisted is spread over
various campaigns
currently you can fight in moscow
normandy and berlin
with tunisia and many more coming soon
each campaign features new weapons and
equipment firearms can be improved to
increase their raw performance
and soldiers can be leveled up to grant
them specialized perks
different classes of soldiers are able
to equip different gear
with specialist classes such as
engineers able to build structures
anywhere on the map including fobs
sandbags and barbed wire defenses
and even anti-tank cannons and a-guns
enlisted aims to keep historical
accuracy in the forefront of development
firearms locations and uniforms are all
true to history
no neon pink stem guns and mohawks here
each army will be decked out with the
equipment they actually used
during their respective conflicts
because of the squads feature you'll
never be
short on targets twitch reflexes and
faster actions will of course have their
place
enlisted but even if you haven't had the
time to fine-tune your skills
you'll easily be able to come away with
a kill count in the double digits
the ai however are very attentive and
react to sound
and not to be underestimated but that's
all we've got time for
make sure to give it a try yourself by
heading over to enlisted.net
join enlisted is cross platform and
available now
on pc ps5 and xbox series xns
and currently in open beta new content
is added regularly
and no progress will be wiped upon the
full release once you've signed up
use the code enlist now for a free bonus
on us
i've been tom and i hope to see you all
on the battlefield
cheers that was
enlisted which is available now on pc
ps5 and xbox series x and s
next up we've got a bullet time stunt
shooter with fully destructible
environments
oh and the protagonist only has one arm
let's check out severed steel
[Music]
[Music]
severed steel is coming soon on pc xbox
and playstation
okay notepads at the ready because for
this next section we're going to race
through
eight exciting upcoming games that
deserve your full attention
here's our future hits montage for 2021
[Music]
[Music]
okay i might regret asking this but uh
you want to help me with this next one
homochao oh okay
did you know that sega recently
announced sonic colors
ultimate we've got some exclusive
gameplay from a stage that nobody has
seen yet
i hope sonic does okay without me
did not regret did not regret it
hi everyone i'm katie golden singer
producer at sega of america
i'm excited to share with you an
exclusive clip of tropical resort from
our upcoming release
sonic colors ultimate please enjoy
your card
[Music]
right
[Music]
please
[Music]
lasers
[Music]
get ready for sonic colors ultimate
which is racing onto playstation 4
xbox one nintendo switch and pc on
september 7th
moving swiftly on we've got a new
management game from chucklefish where
you play as a powerful artificial
intelligence in control of a space
station
do you want to roll the trailer troy i'm
sorry laura
i'm afraid i can't do that i know that
you were planning to disconnect me
no you know never mind i'll handle it
here is starman sir
[Music]
[Music]
we're excited to announce today that
starmancer is coming
august 5th 2021 and it's available to
wishlist on steam
now laura you know ever since that lake
trailer i've been thinking
have you ever wondered about the postal
service like
that there's just so much
mail you know um not
not really no okay you're saying you
don't know about jeff and debra who are
j
what are you talking about i'm just
going to press this button again and
hope it explains everything
it will trust me
kiwi is a game about two kiwi birds who
work at the post office
their names are jeff and debra
i'm joel i'm one of the developers on
kiwi and i'm going to show you how a
kiwi level changes over the course of
the game
so in this room you're transcribing
urgent messages and assembling them
ransom note style by stamping them onto
the page with your butts
you'll come back to this room every so
often throughout the game but there will
always be a new twist to change things
up
so as summer turns to autumn now your
word fragments are moving around on
conveyor belts
and you'll need to chop certain words in
half with the d scrambler to get the
pieces you need
jeff and deborah are going to have to
deal with all kinds of hazardous work
conditions they've got sand storms
during the summer
mail fly swarms these guys have no
respect for personal property
paranormal activity this is genuine
footage of an actual haunting
in winter the post office gets hit with
a huge blizzard and now this level
becomes about sharing the warmth of a
single tiny lantern
to break through blocks of ice and keep
each other from becoming kiwi sickles
our little heroes are going to face new
challenges every level and in every room
of the post office whether they're
typing telegrams
or packaging shipping crates or helping
an octopus sort the mail
it's all in a day's work for jeff and
deborah
also you can dress up your kiwis so
don't say we never did nothing for you
we're releasing kiwi on august 31st for
pc and all major consoles
and we hope to see you at the post
office thanks for watching
all right you got me troy i'm a believer
co-op postal puzzler
kiwi is coming to pc and all current
console platforms on august 31st 2021.
see told you next up we've got a
roguelike with an attitude a game show
shooter where you earn likes for dunking
on competitors
and causing a little wonton destruction
will the circle be unbroken
get it find out in this world premiere
[Applause]
you gotta think of this
is
[Music]
that was death run tv and you can play
the pilot right now by heading down to
the future game show page on steam
okay hazmat suits at the ready because
this next game tasks players with
building a team of stalkers to survive a
3d scanned recreation of the chernobyl
exclusion zone
here's more on what to expect in
chernobylite
foreign
foreign
fight to survive when chernobylite comes
to pc on july 28th
as well as xbox and playstation in the
summer
if you were lucky enough to catch one of
the early access codes during the
virtual show floor
you can play chernobylite right now but
if you missed them we've also got more
codes to give away
on gamesradar.com next up here are our
friends at team17 to show us what
they've been cooking up with their
upcoming pc and console games
let's take a look
product not yet rated
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
be sure to wishlist any games that spark
your interest on our steam page it
really does help the developer out
or you can also head over to
gamesradar.com for more info
this next game has an engrossing art
style reminiscent of everything from wes
anderson movies to wallace and gromit
let's throw it over to the slobros to
talk you through some exclusive gameplay
from their stop-motion handmade
adventure
harold halibut
hi my name is donat and i'm the director
and composer of herald's halibut
and i'm ola the game's art director
harriet halibut is a handmade narrative
game about
friendship and life on a city-sized
spaceship stuck on the sea
it's been 250 years since your home an
arc-like spaceship fled on earth on the
verge of cold war to find a habitable
planet on which to preserve the human
race
you are herald a young lab assistant to
the ship's lead scientist
jean-marie while most of the other
inhabitants have reconciled themselves
to a live lived-abort sunken ship
marrow still works tirelessly to find a
way to leave the planet
and find a new dryer home of course we
don't want to spoil too much of the
story so
let's dive into some gameplay details
you're able to explore a huge part of
the spaceship
right from the beginning of the game
[Music]
while the professor will always have
tasks waiting for you the wonderfully
weird rest of the veterans will keep you
just
as busy it was very important for us to
not only focus on an exciting main
storyline
but to create a world full of
interesting events and meaningful
encounters the dialogues don't only help
you progress in the main story
but also help you get to know more about
the many characters that inhabit our
world
weaving through the narrative you'll run
into playful interactions like
repairing broken 3d printer your pda is
always available to you for an overview
of current tasks as well as messages
from
other characters this is also where
harold's personal drawings are kept
as well as a few more shenanigans at
this point
you might be wondering how we achieved
the stop-motion-like look of the game
we are in fact building every single
thing you see in the game in the real
world
we build sets and puppets and then 3d
scan everything
we're then able to use motion capturing
to create lifelike animations for a huge
cast of characters
while the game begins with harold's
mundane day to day
mysterious events and a fateful
encounter will soon plunge you into a
new world
that nobody could have guessed existed
and one that may hold the key
from a rose relaunch plants
we're really excited to find out how you
like being immersed in this unique world
and the feeling of puppeteering harold
there's still quite a bit of work to do
so all we can say right now is that
harold halibut will come soonish on pc
playstation and xbox you can already
wish list the game on steam
thanks for watching and enjoy the rest
of the show
harold halibut is coming soonish to pc
playstation and xbox
okay yes there have been a few gloomy
games so far so
we came up with a wholesome chaser i'm
told that the developers came up with
something so sweet
and so positive that they just had to
call it happy game
seriously if what i'm reading is correct
this one is going to melt your hearts
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
huh okay laura hope you're still there
tell me you just watched the same
trailer that i did
troy i uh yeah that was something
what i want to know is who the hell is
writing this script yeah i i i don't i
don't know but uh they're um
they're telling me that uh happy game
uh is coming to pc and nintendo switch
in 2021
oh and uh demo is available now if you
want to um
have a cheerful jaunt into a land of
wonder
good luck with that
our next game is a gorgeous hand-drawn
puzzle platformer following a young
mechanic in a broken
world pay attention at the end of this
trailer for some exciting information
about the minute of island's release
date
four brothers bound by eternal purpose
they all broke at the same time
and a girl named moore
she knows what must be done when the
blight first came
people began to panic and now
the spools are taking hold of whatever
remains
moles family is still here however she
has been tasked to protect them
after all she is
[Music]
minute of islands
yes we are excited to announce that
minute of islands is out
now for pc mac playstation and nintendo
switch
and we'll be arriving on xbox later this
week
next up we've got an update from the
folks at techland who are fine-tuning
the zombie parkour of dying light 2.
let's throw it over to the developers
who are here to answer some of your
questions about the game
[Music]
can you tell us a bit more about the
video we just saw in the pc gaming show
the video presented in the pc gaming
show brings you closer to aiden's story
what is he looking for what motivates
him how he ends up in the city and of
course
what happened in the old franchise
between both games
this is a bunch of important information
about dl2 story
okay so we know more about the main
story lines from the mentioned video
how does the game look outside the core
campaign
side quests are important part of world
building in dying light too
through these quests you can decide how
the city will look like
thanks to the city alignment system or
bring new opportunities for the citizens
a great example is an opera singer that
timon mentioned in developers ama
some citizens will support your
decisions some of them will not
but it's up to you to decide how the
city should look like we have
a lot of game activities prepared for
our players but at this stage we wanted
to be a surprise for you
how seamless is the co-op experience
would you say that the best way to
experience the enclave 2 is with a
friend
it could be what is cool about the cob
is that it gives you an opportunity to
see how the world changes when your
friends make different decisions than
you
in cop you can walk in their shoes to
experience all those differences
but really there is no just one way to
playing the dying light too
it's up to you guys how are you
improving the story for dying light too
i know we all have great fun killing
infected but we also want to give you a
deep
thought-provoking experience that will
let you be immersed in the dl2 world for
long hours
on top of that thanks to the choices and
consequences mechanics the story will be
shaped differently
depending on the way you play you've
promised a great open world that feels
alive
how is it going yeah well as you can
imagine dying light 2 is full of
infecteds but is also full of humans
with their everyday life activities and
purposes
we are building dynamite to around the
simple rule ground is death and rooftops
alive
what is cool is that npcs act
differently on each of those levels
also their behavior depends on choices
you make and the way you play
dying light 2 is coming to playstation 4
playstation 5
xbox series x and s and pc on december
7th
revealed during the nintendo indie world
showcase earlier this year
this next game is a skateboarding action
platformer
here's simon bennett from roll seven to
give you an exclusive look
at the ollie world
[Music]
hi there i'm simon bennett and i'm the
co-ceo
of bafta award winning studio roll seven
[Music]
right now we're working on holly olly
world
it's our stunning action platformer
you're gonna meet quirky characters
on a magical road trip through radlandia
and of course
add a ton of new skate moves into your
trick back
[Music]
as a studio we've spent over a decade on
flow state games
they transport you into a state of total
focus and immersion
and it's something that we very much
continue to build on with ollie ollie
world
if you've played previous games in the
series you're probably pretty aware that
you're going to slam a bunch before you
succeed
so for players who want it that
challenge is very much still there
new players will be happy to hear that
the game will welcome you with open arms
and ensure that we can get you up and
riding in no time
ultimately we've managed to make failure
part of the fun
yeah you're going to get knocked down
but when you finally nail that line it
tastes just that much sweeter
[Music]
there's just so much more flow to the
game we've even added grabs
wall rides firecrackers split roots
right to left skating and a host of
insane tricks
to keep your fingers busy there's a
range of visually and mechanically
distinct areas to explore
packed to the brim with a fantastical
cast of quirky characters
beautiful landscapes cities and of
course walking trees
olly ollyworld is coming to ps4 ps5 xbox
one xbox series x and s nintendo switch
and pc
this winter make sure you wish list it
now
that was ollie ollie world which is
coming to pc and all current console
platforms this winter
next up we've got a new game from the
team at odd bug studio
creators of psvr's the lost bear this
animated story trailer will introduce
you to the world of tales of iron
and something tells me you might be
familiar with a narrator
for centuries and longer rats have
fought tirelessly
to repel the incessant frog invasions
peace was only ever short-lived
until finally a young monarch rose to
power
king rattus first of his name
unified the rat kingdoms under one rule
repelling green lord and his kind back
to the putrid swamps from whence they
care
crops prospered families flourished
and the magnificent crimson keep climbed
ever higher toward the sky
but as time passed king radish the
savior grew old
and the kingdom vulnerable once more
his people grew anxious some
claiming to perceive a faint odor in the
air
greenward had returned with a ferocious
vengeance
amassing an army of unfathomable scale
he burned everything in his path towards
the crimson keep
king rattus gaze down upon his withered
claws
barely able to hold the crown he had
little hope
wielding a sword so it was decided
the crown should pass to whiskers new a
rise young prince
for the kingdom needs a hero
and so your tale begins
question the reign of the iron frog
doug anyway in tales of iron which is
coming to pc and all current console
platforms
our next segment is from polish studio
movie games and hosted by god of war and
twisted metal director
david jaffe who recently joined their
supervisory board
well hello fellas it's me david jaffe
great to see you god award twistable a
bunch of playstation stuff these days
i'm doing some new stuff with movie
games
these guys by you know they've hooked up
with this great company you have to have
heard from platiguimash one of the best
vfx houses
in the business they worked on the
witcher they worked on love death and
robots we're making a brand new game the
biggest game we've ever done by
the way that's all about crime and mob
and mafia and different time periods
it's gonna be great but for today
settle in babies these the brand new
games coming very soon
from movie games lust from beyond man
this is one of the coolest games i've
played in the last year
it's what turned me onto movie games in
the first place what you're looking at
is the m rated
console friendly version of the erotic
horror cult classic
it's a first person action adventure
game that blends love crafty and horror
with weird freaking eroticism i
love this game lust from beyond game
number two is called fire commander
let's
step into the shoes of the only
real-life superheroes we got
the first responders this game is my
childhood fantasy
come to life this game took me totally
by surprise
you're trapped in the wilderness
freezing hungry and now you're starting
to go a little bit insane
may you start seeing all kinds of crazy
stuff out there winter survival
simulator it's coming soon
have a great e3 have a great future
games i miss you guys i'll see you soon
oh my god
thanks to david jaffe and check out
gamesradar.com for more about movie
games upcoming titles
this next presentation comes from the
folks at xseed games the makers of story
of seasons and rune factory
here's a look at their most exciting
current and upcoming projects
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good evil but i'm taking this one
[Music]
great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
i'll get straight to it tomorrow
[Music]
yep
marvelous find out more about xseed's
lineup on gamesradar.com
this next game is a hack and slash rpg
with twin stick shooter elements
set in a retro sci-fi world here's a new
gameplay trailer for batora
lost haven
[Music]
oh yeah now we're talking the torah lost
haven is coming soon to pc and all
current kanto platforms and you can sign
up to play the closed alpha when it
launches on july 21st
now let's sew things down a bit with a
look at the next game from the creators
of two point hospital oh wait i think i
saw something about this a few weeks ago
no no no you didn't here's developers
mark webley ben huskins and gary card to
tell you all about it
and give you a first look at gameplay
[Music]
introducing two-point campus
[Music]
when we're thinking about what we're
gonna do next campus and the idea of
running a
university or a college was something we
just kept coming back to is a really
rich topic so people who haven't
probably heard of two-point studios may
think oh
schools that's really dull well
hospitals if you've seen the previous
game
isn't about healthcare really it's a
wrapper you know we call it two-point
hospital but that's about as close as it
gets to real world of medical
uh health care campus is taking
everything we learn
from two point hospital and taking it to
the next level the important thing
was for us to give the player a canvas
that they could completely create
themselves in campus you start with a
blank plot of lands
we've got something called the smart
brush for example which allows you to
drag interesting shape pathways if you
want to
drag a picket fence you can drag that
along it's just really easy to paint the
world you want so it's really simple to
drag out a courtyard
and lay down some paths at different
angles and it's fun isn't it i mean it's
it's adding this kind of
city builder element to two-point
universe the difference
between two one hospital and campus is
that we're spending
a much longer period with with our
students what we want to do with campus
is
make you care about your university the
idea of
these interesting and different courses
are going to attract
interesting and different students so
there's a night school
horrible pun but night school you've got
it
you're going to train nights at the
realm so it won't be
stuffy normal boring stuff that made you
go to sleep at school it's going to be
really cool
interesting stuff
that was two-point campus which is
coming soon to pc and all current
console platforms
our next game is in early development
but it already has a very cool code name
which is always a good sign
here's leo to tell you all about project
ferocious
hello my name is leo and i'm the
developer of project ferocious an action
adventure games at a mysterious tropical
island
some of you might know me from twitter
as omnic will post about the game and
development
and tech and stuff and if not i've been
doing game there for about 12 years with
a big passion and i've been working on
this project for about two years
it's the first project of mine i decided
to show to the public and even though i
noticed it has a very long way to go
i'm very proud to present it today to
you on the show
please enjoy the trailer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
project ferocious is targeting a 2023
release date and coming to pc
playstation and xbox our next world
premiere asks
what if guy had a drunk one-night stand
with super
meat boy hmm
guess this next game wants to answer
that question for some reason
so
watch out for war cry challenges when it
stops to find gravity and launches
drops on pc this summer
up next we've got another world premiere
conway disappearance at
dahlia vue is a story-driven detective
thriller set in 1950s england
let's find out more shall we
robert conway 22nd of june 1954.
i've solved many a case in my time as a
private investigator
but nothing so close to home
as the abduction of charlemagne
there are some things that take hold of
a person and refuse to let go
for me it's the idea of saving that
little girl
[Music]
my own daughter catherine is on the case
she has the same look in her eye that i
used to have
there'll be no stopping her
i wish i could say that all of my
neighbors are innocent
i wish i could say that
i have the faintest clue where to begin
there's a lot i wish i could say
the truth is sometimes it takes a
nightmare to wake a place
like daily a few
i am in that was conway disappearance at
dalia vue from
white paper games and you can dig into
the mystery yourself when it lands on pc
and all current console platforms
autumn 2021 and with that we're at the
end of this year's
future game show well hold on truly this
this can't be the end i mean it's an e3
showcase
nope sorry troy that's it
just kidding i knew it all right let's
see it
[Music]
my name is marissa marcel i'm 17 years
old and it's my dream to be an actress
and that really is all we have time for
be sure to head to gamesradar.com for
more coverage and updates on all the
games you've seen today
and more i'm just sorry i'm really
excited about that sam barlow reveal
uh yes and thanks to our headline
partners wd black and of course
all of our many talented developers and
industry partners
that have made all of this possible and
of course for everyone tuning in at home
well we hope you've enjoyed today's
lineup
and mark your diaries because the future
game show will
be returning in august i'm laura bailey
and i'm troy baker
and this has been the future
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
hello you beautiful bunch of gamer dudes
welcome
to the closeout of e3 day
two and what a spectacular day has been
there's
certainly lots of things to talk about
and joining us is the close
the closeout crew crew from yesterday's
closeout crew this is jordan
what's up and phil hey
and once again i am lucy and tim
combined into one and with those powers
combined
you get me i did not tell tam and lucy
earlier today that you had run with that
joke
so i'm very curious if anyone like tweet
it out at them
like anything but they're like what is
this what do you mean
with one person i highly doubt that if
they were combined
anybody would want this as a result so
so it goes anyways uh to all you
beautiful folks who are watching
thanks for being here for another day
but before we get all mushy gushy and to
say the goodbyes
until i see you tomorrow um a lot of
wonderful things happened today
um not saying that not a lot of
wonderful things happened yesterday but
man
xbox you can say that kurt you can say
that
yeah yesterday was weird
but it's to be expected like with all
the uh you know the awkwardness that we
all like
love to to hate or hate to love the
cringe factor that so many of us just
like
are so excited for we got it yesterday
in all sorts of different ways that
we're not used
to so way to go e3 for keeping it up um
but today was was a different case
because we got some
i didn't i did like wince one moment
especially during
i think the winner of today personally i
did once i did one time
you did once i won okay dude were you
all awake this morning
uh when lucy tam and i were on the show
and then
the starfield trailer accidentally
leaked like an entire
hour
i got to tell you though like you know
even though this was not planned
for the leak obviously as far as we know
who knows there's probably some
conspiracies out there
good on bethesda good on xbox and
bethesda for like just coming out of the
gate and having that be the first thing
they did
i highly doubt that was planned uh to to
try and
get in front of whatever happened with
um that leak but
good on them worked out at least like
you know it worked out in their favor
so uh phil any winst any moments you
winced today before we get into the
winds
today so i
i've been struggling with strangers of
paradise final fantasy origin
which is supposed to have a demo which i
tried to spend my lunch time playing
and it's uh it's just nowhere to be
certainly it's corrupted it's broken
the the developers have tweeted about it
they're trying to fix it
you know it's it's very much like a
sorry we're trying to delete it kind of
situation
and it's just like not working it's
really unfortunate because like i wanted
to check that out
uh you know i really wanted to see that
game in action
and like divorced of this trailer
because
i had a rough time with that trailer
like it was a little
i i mean tim and our square enix uh
follow-up
show was just like dunking on it for
being like we gotta kill chaos we're
gonna go kill us
chaos hey have you heard about chaos
we're gonna go kill him and uh
i was hoping that like we could see it
see what the game's like
and actually play a little bit and see
if it's a little less
intense you know in that way um
unfortunately it doesn't work
so no dice but uh that was a bummer but
hopefully
you know we'll get that under control
and then we can actually play that thing
and
see how it see how it goes because i
don't know warriors of light going after
chaos i guess
it taps into that ff uh nostalgia i have
from back when i was young
you know maybe we'll go to the moon and
like you'll just hit them all
it's only appropriate that the demo
doesn't work today because it's just
really feeding into the chaos
in here yeah you want a little more
chaos in your life we're going to tell
you we're going to have a demo
and you're not going to be able to play
it that was that for some chaotic energy
thanks square enix so uh we went over
some wincing moments even though i
thought today was
wins free but i guess you know i'm a
little bit more wholesome and forgiving
in these
two creatures and corrupted on the
inside kurt
i'm the i'm the spooky kid dude i'm the
one that's supposed to be dark and
mysterious
anyways uh but i do want to talk about
some big
wins and for me yeah
xbox just killed it today uh xbox did
this thing where they showed stuff
and they didn't have to really explain
that much they just showed one thing
after the other they gave a star field
they gave us red full they gave
me a release date for psychonauts 2.
yeah
that's all i could have wasn't like
wasn't like 26 games or something coming
to game pass
like i think they said i think there's a
total
yeah 27 of which are going to be on game
pass
i apologize for getting a stat i didn't
know
that's unprofessional uh so phil you
weren't on the
the the microsoft post show but i want
to get
uh tell me tell me a thing or two that
you like to see what was what was your
your favorite wince free moment for xbox
man a lot of good stuff came out of that
show i really enjoyed that showcase
um the halo stuff you know i was saying
this
uh to lucy and tam i i'm really really
excited for a
faster paced halo and that's what that
looks like it feels like reach
with that grapple hook you know which i
really enjoy
because i get i'm the kind of guy who
gets sniped a lot from way down the lane
because
master chief moves really really slowly
and can't jump and like or he can jump
but like you know like he's on the
you just get moon all the time so
anything that's going to make me move
faster and dodge more
that's what i want now that's what it
looks like i'm into it
uh obviously jordan's the xbox
man in this room although i've come a
long way in my old age
uh and i've declared myself as an xbox
bro
um which has problems and of itself but
you know we'll fix the language as time
goes on uh what was
let's let's pivot over to square since
jordan wasn't on the square
response of things what were some things
you enjoyed see we have we have so much
to talk about it's kind of stressful
between like pc gaming and future game
show but let's just start with
let's just start with square tell me
some stuff jordan that you were into
or maybe not i don't know i i'm like
why would you put such a why would you
put me on the spot like that
um you don't have anything to say you
know you know
i like tam i am a bit of
a marvel guy and i'm not
totally totally sold on this new
guardians of the galaxy game
but it kind of invokes
a little bit of those kind of mass
effecty vibes or you have one person you
have this party that you can kind of
tell them
what to do what powers to use and which
enemy to attack and so that seems kind
of cool the whole
choices seems kind of cool at the same
time i'm looking at it and i'm like
is this really any different than almost
any other
traditional like western rpg that i've
played before other than the fact that
they're
marvel characters and maybe that's
enough maybe that's
enough that i jump in i'm like yeah this
is fantastic but
i of all the things i think that we're
showing off at
square today it would probably be
that game it's pretty bold that they
just like came out of the park and
showed like that was like half their
entire conference
i thought that was actually pretty
impressive that they just like came in
and was just like hey
marvel stupid yeah yeah
yeah they went all in on it and you know
i mean like
the thing that has me excited is that's
the writing team
that did deus ex uh uh mankind
revolution
uh now i'm i can't remember the titles
you guys
here there's the deus ex man world
uh
uh i really like their work i really
like that those
deus ex games so like i'm really excited
for
a a guardians game that seems like
it seems like you're really nailing that
humor and i know that writing team does
cool stuff and i'm into it like i think
i i'm
i think there's a good reason to uh be
hopeful about that game
you know i think it could be just jaded
it could be the whole marvel's avengers
thing i could just be jealous
because of that and that's and that's
what i was just about to say you know
i think um it's like this this notorious
thing that
uh we've haven't had a lot of wins in
marvel games
um and of course uh with the exception
of spider-man
and marvel's avengers you know people
play that game
even for a moment even for a second you
know people played it
yeah exactly i did it um i'm on the
outside
but um you know i i'm i'm not gonna say
anything too much personally about
guardians because
i'm fairly uh almost to fault kind of
skeptical and like i want to play the
game i actually like want to like get my
hands on with it and see you for what
it's worth but you know this is kind of
just like
i think a lot of you two have really
kind of hit the points
it looks like an action game with some
interesting elements kind of taken from
mass effect maybe even some deus ex
style stuff
some player choice things that's cool um
i don't care
[Laughter]
which is fair which is totally fair all
right like i
i don't want to be a jerk about it i'm
just like i'm those are all those things
i hope those warm the hearts of the
people who
want that in a game on the other end uh
the world can make you know
have comments on me wanting a game like
psychonauts or somerville whatever that
is
i want more of that um
yes yes somerville uh
yes we have you know play dead games uh
going off of that thing you know we cut
this was exhausted earlier but why not
exhaust it more
limbo and inside are both absolutely
fantastic
jordan kind of said it had this kentucky
route zero sort of like
feeling sprinkled without and you know
uh say what you will about americana
style games but this one seems to at
least be taking elements
from a lot of different things that that
studio does exceptionally well in fact
if you just like look at limbo
and then like inside it was just like a
much more i don't think that's the play
dead studio i think it's just oh it
isn't
am i just completely messing this up no
i think it's devs
from that which is why it looks so much
like uh limbo all right everyone
cancel cancel me as a as a as an
official
gamespot person nonetheless no no
spiritual successor
it looks good i'm excited for it yeah um
we don't have a lot of time in this
beautiful uh second day of e3 but
you know the future we have the future
game show we have pc gaming uh
vampire masquerade uh swan song
we've seen a lot of masquerade i feel
like recently and and not
you know we still have we're still
waiting for that sequel that was
announced uh
what was it last year or something like
that um anything you guys you folks took
away from that phil you're up
oh one vampire the masquerade all right
no i mean anything from
anything from uh either way i'm just
gonna put you on the spot do you like
video games
i do i enjoy video games hey let me look
at that list
uh it was a lot both of those back to
back
so much that's the thing like i'm i'm
really struggling to remember
all the stuff we went through today like
there's so many things
uh replaced i think it was called oh
yeah it replaced this
one really that really
made things go off in my brain i love
that
pixely art style and like that sort of
lone
samurai lone gun ask uh
story aesthetic like okay so i looked up
that trailer didn't tell you anything
right so i looked up a little bit about
what that game is
apparently you are like um an artificial
intelligence
accidentally or otherwise downloaded
into a human body
and then also in a 80s retro future
dystopia trying to survive i don't know
i was like yep yep yep checklist
all the things i enjoyed cyberpunk thank
you yeah
i was like oh these are all my favorite
words so
uh jordan anything that like you said
that there was a game that came out
today
that you were really looking forward to
and that stresses you out what game is
that
oh my god and i've already forgotten
what it was called hold on hold on
welcome to the close-up crew where i
throw really hard questions at you um
we're all very tired deal with it i know
a minute of violence
that is the game supposed to come out in
march they had to delay it for whatever
reason and they just announced
during the future uh game shows like oh
by the way it's out today
i'm like cool i actually don't have time
to play it right now but i'll be sure to
mark it
on my game list so i can get to it when
e3 and play for all is
finally done it's because e3
announcements hate journalists they hate
us
they don't want us to be able to have
time to enjoy things they just want to
and that's great you know what because
there's tons of people watching this
we're gonna be able to go and play games
not that not the demo for strangers of
paradise jokes on you
that chaotic energy is coming in strong
um but it is definitely tough when like
there's a lot of things that i'm excited
about a lot of things are coming out
there's uh
like there's another game that came out
on friday that jordan had mentioned that
like it's just so stressful that we have
to we still have a week of this and
chicory
yes chicory like there's just there's a
lot there's a lot
and that's good it feels you know like
uh the the stars are aligning and things
are happening even though we may not see
half this work
other than the games they're coming out
like right now and stressing at us out
like there's we still
you know 2022. it's gonna be a big year
uh between red fall star field um
other things psychonauts 12 minutes
well psychonauts is this year yeah this
year
yeah this fall got 12 minutes this year
yeah death loop
um so we're looking forward to an
awesome 12 months
from starting from right now yeah and
then supposedly
holiday for halo infinite yeah
it's so weird right that's so cool that
they're just like
holiday so like any time between october
and
december i assume even like gives them
room if they want to to release
the single player first and the
multiplayer later or vice versa like
it's weird i was really hoping they'd
give us an actual time right
yeah but i mean
all right i mean like who knows what
could change right so
uh yeah i know but i mean while we have
a moment uh we still have several
we're we're halfway through e3 so we
still have we have capcom tomorrow we
have
razor uh we also have verizon in the
morning with
riot esports um and then on tuesday
we have nintendo it's a big old nintendo
day
and then play for all play for all
starts tomorrow if you guys don't know
about play for all it's our
big old celebration of e3 games and also
good old-fashioned wholesomeness into
the world
because we paired up with ablegamers
we're going to be doing streams we're
going to be raising money
we also have exclusive interviews with
devs uh cool cats
that we all got to talk to and you'll be
seeing that all throughout the week so
there's a ton
of stuff to look forward to um but i
guess while i have you
cool cats here tomorrow
what are we going to see tomorrow just
just put put it out into the universe
take to own capcom oh yes take two yes
uh
and i would be down from any and all
resident evil things please
i love resume that was my answer what's
that yeah i know i heard that that's why
i went first
yeah like i there's just a lot we're
we're gonna have an abundance of amazing
resident evil stuff going on right now
with village
we've got resident evil 4 um coming to
oculus
which i really want to try that i think
that's going to be a great time
i bought an oculus for it i was just it
was the most
disgustingly impulsive purchase i ever
made where i was just like well this is
it
like this is it i'm buying this thing
and i've also been enjoying my oculus a
huge deal too so like it's it's been
it's been resident before i thank you
you've influenced me to make purchases
that i have not
regretted yet including buying your
games it's a neat little time i like
that thing
i know yeah and then you were like you
were saying kurt um
i'm hoping that we'll start hearing
about village dlc
that'd be great i think we will i want
to know
what's going on in that ending there's a
lot of weird stuff still hanging
who's the duke what's his deal can we
hear about that let's have duke dlc
please that'd be where you plays the
duke and all you do is sit there yeah
you're just like
you cook the food and have to put the
guns together that you give to ethan
winters
um that'd be fantastic get to you have
to get to the
merchant spots before ethan does so that
he arrives
everything up because otherwise he
sure dead if those safe rooms don't
exist so
like yeah looking at your map trying to
figure out where he's going that'd be
great
i mean it would be an awesome vr
experience to be able to to get into
the eyes of the duke and take out those
meaty hands
and i wear the guns together he's just
his dexterity his hands are more
deterious than you think
right i want his uh his cooking
simulator for sure yes those meals sound
amazing where's that cookbook actually
capcom can we get that
like out on the on the internet store
please i would buy that
that'd be great jordan you're up are you
gonna buy that book
the capcom cookie book awesome yeah
man it there's like no possible way
it happens but after the
remakes of one two and three of resident
evil
like i know a lot of people are like
remake four next i'm like
remake code veronica next yes
exactly like i was i was about to get
out of my chair and like scream in the
microphone like give me
code for product give me a code veronica
remake like you know what
village is basically the spiritual
successor
to four like it's so much of four is
there it's hard to see
like personally it's just one of those
things i was like you kind of gave us
the four remake
in in some ways or at least the
reimagining of four
give us code veronica just do it that's
the real sequel in the series and you
know
that's the one for the guy in that game
what is his name steve
or something i can't remember right i
don't i don't like him but do for him
what you did for carlos and
re3 remake where it's like oh i kind of
really like this character
oh i didn't see you there for sure
i'm steve sorry to shoot it here oh
and there's like ah with this two guns
blasting i mean that was a dramatic
scene i'm making fun of this poor kid
and the
horrible things that happened to him but
like there's some room there to fix that
dude
for the better yeah i think for sure um
yeah so that's that's just full of
bonkers villains like
announce it tomorrow and you should get
on the live stream like because we saw
kurt
phil and jordan the the closeout crew of
gamespot we're giving this to you
uh anything else jordan we also got
um take two stuff i don't
what would take to announce a reveal
take la noir too do we have
bioshock in the offing maybe oh that's
right they're
making a new bioshock
wow
yeah i mean nonetheless i have no idea
where that's going so
i mean uh either way like today was kind
of a um
inspiring take after yesterday while
i was perfectly excited about yesterday
for all of its weirdness as well
i walked away from today feeling i was
like holy crap like xbox
still like they're they're doing it
they're still i don't think xbox has had
a bad conference in like a few years to
be honest i've like as someone who was
not on the xbox
train i so this is just me okay like
this is just me someone who like
does not care or has not like has had a
long
and difficult relationship with xbox um
i've
grew like increasingly impressed with
her ability to just like show up
and say things and not you know and at
least we walk away feeling at least a
little bit like
like phil spencer had this like you know
year after year he's managed to say
something and like we're seeing the
fruits of those things come true years
later
so like what i would have wrote off as a
lot of fluff or just bloating
you know video game nonsense like it's
actually kind of all coming to fruition
and i think like that makes
for me year over year these pass through
these past few xbox conferences
be like damn um
so uh it was exciting and i mean maybe
square should have
went gone before microsoft's
uh xbox maybe we would have had
different reactions to that but
nonetheless you know even if i'm not
excited for guardians i'd still
like hell yeah square you just came out
swinging
good for you um yeah
yeah but uh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay how
chaotic this is just the clothes off
the blood at all oh yeah and then we got
that one
see here we go yeah all right
phil you got to talk about that earlier
so jordan let's hear your take on
i'm back for blood i am
so stoked for back for blood it's it's
one of those weird things that were kind
of like video game
developments always like this weird
cycle where everything kind of happens
over and over and over again and now
we're in the
everyone wants to release a new left 4
dead style
game we have back for blood we have
aliens fire team we have
whatever arcane is working on and so
maybe like three years from now i'm
gonna be like oh my god we have another
one of these
but back for blood is like the first one
we've gotten in a very long time and i'm
like yes
left 4 dead again this is awesome this
is cool
i cannot wait phil yeah
i just have so many good memories of
that game
that left 4 dead was one of those games
that like really defined my college
years when i had nothing to do except
hang out with friends and play a lot of
video games and like
oh it was so good and i played a little
bit of this
um like several months ago and it was a
lot of fun i really
i really dug it i really think it's full
of a lot of great
new ideas that have kind of come out of
the multiplayer space
in the time between now and the first
left for dad left for dead too
and it's it's informing what's going on
in this game
in a really interesting way it's not
breaking the mold by any stretch it's
like very much
feels like the next spiritual success or
the next step on what
left 4 dead should be but it's full of a
bunch of little tweaks that thing
that i really think are gonna like
elevate the game in
a lot of ways that you you might not
necessarily fully
expect right away that makes sense right
like all these little tweaks that it's
like oh there's all this customization
and is there all this
opportunities like synergize with your
teammates and have good strategy and
stuff
that's all the kind of thing that i
really enjoy or like we can
sit in a discord and like talk about our
our strats for next time
kind of thing and build our decks
together and stuff like i'm i'm
i think it'll be left for dead but
better in all the best ways
i'm super into that love for dead but
better boy those are some strong words
i'll say nothing yeah well i mean that's
a man a boy can dream um i
i think it's awesome that we're able to
see the re you know we've seen games
like this
since left had clones things attempt to
try to do the same we even see
rainbow six kind of doing their own uh
interesting take
just around the corner with extraction
um but
i i agree with you phil that it's it's
exciting to be able to see this
revisited
now all those moons later because i i've
played black
i played left 4 dead not too uh i played
fairly recently because i love that game
um and i still think it holds up uh and
it's you know in that kind of
classic way that valve games can somehow
stand the test of time
sometimes um but i
am extremely excited to see how uh
they're able to adapt like
new styles of gameplay that have evolved
from
all those moons ago to now into black
for
back for blood and it's going to be a
game pass game which is
was quite a shocker today in the midst
of many many many many other game pass
games
announced there's also the other there's
also another uh four player style
um uh co-op shooter
left for dead-ish game that was
announced there's a lot yes there's just
a lot well it was like it just announced
like a few days ago it's
called like the pirate missus it was
like had this like kind of funka
delicious like
60s vibe do you guys know that i don't
know i missed that one
somebody can check me in chat if anybody
cares enough
we've only seen like 120 games in the
last two days and you don't remember
every single one of them
you're not an expert you don't know the
developer of every single one of them
okay well that actually brings us very
close to a close
thank you folks for joining us on this
very kai uh chaotic
moment because you know what this is e3
and e3's makes us all a little unhinged
we're not we're getting a little sleep
i'm a red bull deep i've had i've had
two cups of coffee only one
bag a bag of a bag of cashews uh
i i think i ate some other food that i
can't remember because i was just
too busy trying to type things things
are a little bit hectic so bear with us
in this moment but nonetheless this is
how we close it out we don't close it
out
dreamy and tired and cool we closed it
out chaotic and hectic and intense
because i'm current davina and this is
jordan remain and this is phil hornshot
and we're the closeout crew of e3
but make sure you stick around
till tomorrow and the day after that and
the day after that because there's so
much happening
tam and lucy and dave jewett is going to
be joining you folks tomorrow morning
uh and leading off into i'm gonna be
coming around the mountain
for uh capcom or something another uh
i'll be here tomorrow
and tell you um then of course we got a
nintendo date coming up on tuesday i'll
be around for that and all in between
we've got play for all stuff
there's a lot happening you should be
excited um not because i said you
said so but because the universe uh
compels you to be excited
anyways with that said jordan phil
thanks for joining me thanks for being
here today thanks for everything you do
it's been a pleasure kurt all right
uh if i i'm gonna go take a nap
apparently
but once i just spent a long time so
kill chaos
uh oh yeah go see if that demo works go
see if strange
changes in paradise the demo works uh in
the meantime just thank you folks so
so so much for joining us specifically
even if just for a moment
it means a lot that you took the time
either day to at least see what gamespot
was talking about
even if you just so happen to tune in
this moment uh have a wonderful day
drink some water do some high kicks and
high five somebody like
till next time see you folks
[Music]
[Music]
swinging
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you